what image to your clients paints of
ghilane Maxwell she was in charge and
without Yellin the the Jeffrey Epstein
that everybody grew tend to to know the
monster that was that altum Utley was
able to gain access to dozens and dozens
if not over a hundred female victims he
couldn't have existed I mean she created
him
she was an integral part of the grooming
process and some for some of them it was
years later before they really realized
that that's what would what had happened
but not many who really knew her liked
her and most of them after a while grew
to realize she was deceiving them all
along and in helping to facilitate what
turned out to be some pretty brutal
crimes how significant is this
development for your many clients very I
mean it's a long time coming and I've
spoken with many of my clients today
some of whom had a lot of interactions
with Gillan and others who had none but
either way all of them were extremely
relieved and understand the importance
of this particular arrest will your
clients be willing to testify against
Kelly Maxwell I don't know any clients
of mine who would not be willing to
testify you know at this point in time
they're they're all very brave very
courageous and you know there's strength
in numbers and over time they all have
gained more inner strength over time you
get these real strong voices like Maria
farmer and Courtney wild and Virginia
Roberts and Sara ransom until it kind of
steam rolls to the point that they just
won't give up
and they really instill strength and the
other victims to where now there's just
this great big voice and these the
survivors of this particular abuse by
Jeffrey Epstein
arguing I've never seen a stronger voice
you know so you will not see a
prosecution this time it falls apart
because the victims aren't willing
that's just not happening what's your
reaction to Prince Andrei's statements
on this he says he's bewildered at the
suggestion he hasn't been cooperating
with the US authorities his bewilderment
is subsidiary to my bewilderment because
he's been personally invited to provide
all the information he knows for more
than a decade I know personally for over
a decade we've been asking him to come
and provide all of the information that
he has I think I've personally invited
him at least three times to tell us what
he knows and he just flat out refuses I
mean as much as he keeps putting out
these statements that he's been wildered
and he doesn't understand or whatever
it's not faring very well for him he
clearly has information he stayed at mr.
Epstein's
various residences for a period of time
he met a lot of people who are now
making it very well known that they were
also victims he's been a longtime friend
of Gillan Maxwell he was a very close
friend of Jeffrey Epstein he clearly
made observations heard things saw
things and engaged in they enough with
people to where if you have nothing to
hide
or if you know information come share it
if you don't it certainly makes you look
a certain way and that way is not good
you think he's deliberately you know
evading authorities there's no doubt
that he's deliberately evading
authorities I mean how much more clear
when have you ever heard a US Attorney's
Office at a press conference say we are
inviting you to come over and he's still
he's not on a plane right now coming
over you know there's no doubt that they
want to talk to him there's no doubt
that we have wanted to talk to him and
there's also no doubt that he hasn't
spoken with anybody so this is not
helpful for him unless he immediately
comes over and shares all of the
information he has
I don't I just don't see how he has any
credibility left on this particular
subject how do your clients feel about
his relative silence bewildered angry
yeah well you know JIT they're more
angry at the various statements that
he's made about you know that he he's
offered to be cooperative you know these
things that there's clients who know him
there's clients who are familiar with
the fact that he was around and you know
they they're familiar with the evidence
they know that he was on the flight logs
they know that he was in gülen's
apartment with Virginia Roberts
they know that there are hard questions
that he should be answering especially
if there's any bit of deface for his own
actions then these are things that he
should he should be you know kind of
owning up to and the fact that he's not
is very frustrating to the victims the
tip to them it's kind of like Jeffrey
Epstein and Gulen
why are you able to live above the law
and that's what he's doing she avoided
the cameras to some extent she avoided
the authorities though it would appear
that they had been discreetly tracking
her for some time yeah I mean so so I
think that the public at large may not
have known where she was but anybody who
really needed to know where she was knew
where she was and I think that the
prosecutors move pretty quick on this
because you're talking about very
historic crimes that they're
investigating they've been very
deliberate in the way that they have
investigated very thorough I mean I can
tell they tell you that personally
they've been very thorough in the way
that they've investigated that and you
know it's only one year to the
anniversary of Jeffrey Epstein being
arrested and and they they indicted us
so you know given that you're talking
about crimes twenty-five years old a
year period of time to make sure that
you've crossed her
and dot your eyes isn't really that long
and they had a pulse on on her
whereabouts little time
you